कि नमस्कार शर्मा जी के हिंदी में के
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में आप का स्वागत है
कि आज हम सीखने वाले हैं बहुत ही
इंपोर्टेंट कंसेप्ट कि जर्मन में कंजक्शन
कंजंक्शंस मतलब जिनको हिंदी में बोलते हैं
समुच्चय बोधक की जो दो या उससे ज्यादा
वर्ड्स को यह सेंटेंसेस को जोड़ते हैं और
यह बहुत इंपोर्टेंट है दोस्तों कि देर
सबसे पहले हमने क्या सीखा कि अल्फाबेट्स
कि आप ही सीढ़ी उसके बाद हमने उससे वर्ड्स
बनाएं वर्ड्स हमने वाक्य बनाएं सेंटेंसेस
बनाएं अभी आप यह सेंटेंस को जोड़ने वाले
हैं तो इससे आपको जो विचार है उस पर किलो
मिलता है मतलब मैं क्रिकेट खेलता हूं मुझे
क्रिकेट पसंद है मैं क्रिकेट खेलता हूं
क्योंकि मुझे क्रिकेट पसंद है कि जो
क्योंकि हैं या और है यार है यह सारे
कंजंक्शंस है इंग्लिश में व होंगे ऐड और
बट वगैरह तो आज हम वैसे ही सबसे
इंपोर्टेंट 6 कंजक्शन सीखेंगे किसी भी
लैंग्वेज में बहुत सारे ऐसे होते हैं
हिंदी में भी देखिए एक सिर्फ पर है उसका
भी किंतु-परंतु कितने हो सक
अपने हम सबसे इंपोर्टेंट हैं वॉच ने वाले
तो करें शुरू
को सबसे पहले यह तीन सबसे इजी सबसे बेस्ट
फूड ऑर्डर उड़ मतलब एंड तो हम सबको पता है
हमें नंबर्स में ठीक है आर्डर मतलब और और
और आवर मतलब बट आप पर मतलब बट यह तीनों
एकदम सिंपल है क्या करना है दो सेंटेंस
लोक बीच में है डाल दो कस्टम आपका हो गया
सेंटेंस तैयार है हाइब्रिड को एंड यू
ड्रिंक पेप्सी इस ट्रिक को कुंदूर
प्रिंटहेड सी कटर सिर्फ उनको बीच में
डालिए नहीं आई कैन प्ले क्रिकेट और
विकेंद्रित हैरी पॉटर अगेन प्ले क्रिकेट
और वे कैन रीड हैरी पॉटर इस कारण क्रिकेट
पिलर है
का पाउडर और वी एम उन्हें डॉक्टर ने है
लास्ट म आई लाइक इट बट्टा प्लेटें हिस
लेफ्ट बटक टेनिस इस मास्क क्रिकेट मार्क्स
लाइक यू कैन स्टिल अलाइव उसका शुरू होता
है मार्क इस मास्क रिक्वेस्ट आ तरफ बीच
में रोड़ा इस पिलर टेनिस कुछ भी नहीं देखो
अगर आप ऊपर से जाकर देखो तो सिर्फ उन
गोरापन को बीच में हादसों सेंटेंस साले
आपका हो गया 3 आपको कंटेंशंस मिल गए आई10
आई20 जेएनयू वेट वर्कर स्पीशीज आफ उर्दू
इस पर अगर कुछ भी नहीं है टीम व्हाट्सएप
को तीन कंजंक्शन आने लगी दूसरा जो प्रकार
है वह बहुत इंपोर्टेंट है दोस्तों क्योंकि
अगर आपको यह समझ में आया तो आपको जर्मन के
बहुत सारे एडवांस का अनशन की समझ में
आयेंगे तो इसमें क्या होता है तो बेसिकली
यह कहां जाता है वह जगत में इसको उपवास के
बोलते हैं पवार
का प्रस्ताव बोर्ड क्लास इंग्लिश में
उल्टे नहीं पेट साफ उनके साथ आते हैं तो
इन्हें विशेष तहत वर्ग-3 कौन से देखते हैं
कौन से इंटरकोर्स वाइल्ड वाइल्ड मतलब मौत
को वॉल्व वो मतलब कि वनों के वनों और
वैल्यू मतलब युवतियां व कंडिशनर तो इनमें
क्या होता है समझ लो यह अगर आपको समझ में
आया तो आपको बहुत सारी है जो प्रॉपर
कंसेप्ट है आपको समझना है इन में क्या
होता है यह बॉयल्ड के बाद यह वैद्य उबाल
के बाद जो सेंटेंस है का या उसमें जो चैनल
में चलने वाला वर्ड है उसमें जो वर्ड चले
का या कन्ज्यूगेट होगा उच्च वर्ग गुर्जरों
सेकंड मजबूत होता है उसको उठाओ और एंड में
लेकर जाओ
कल सुबह उठाओ एंड में लेकर जाओ यह कंसेप्ट
आपको समझ में आए तो आपका डाल है क्या करना
है जो फाइल ओं वॉल वैन के बाद जो सेंटेंस
जा रहा है आपका उसमें से सेकेंड पोजीशन के
वर्क उठाना है या चलने वाले वर्क उठाना है
एंड मिडल है डेविड थोरो एग्जाम पास करते
हैं तो आपको समझ में आएगा तो यह खुद
ए अा ई ड्रिंक आईटी बिकॉज व्हाईल आईटी
आईएस रिक्वेस्टेड टो सेल आईटी विद सेंटेंस
अलग-अलग क्या है इस ट्रिक घंटे इस्मार्ट
कि जब वहीं से जोड़ेंगे इस प्रेम करते
बॉईल सेकेंड पोजीशन का मार्ग एंड में
जाएगा व इश्ते मांग
ए सिंपल वे था इसलिए सेकेंड पोजीशन पावर
चलने वाला वर्ग ग्रुप के एडमिन है
सिमिलरली आईडेंटिटी वन तो अलाइव कॉफी कॉफी
पसंद करते हुए चावल इस ट्रिक डे इस मास्क
पे इस ट्रिक करते हो बूंद इश्क पे मां के
प्रति श्रमिक नेता बना तो जिम्मेदार दूर
होता है 100 08:21 एम एल ए
ए स्ट्रिंग करते इस हफ्ते में स्प्रिंकलर
टैग वेनिश मिर्च हां अब एक Simple सेकेंड
पोजीशन कवर चलने वाला ग्रुप के एडमिन
कि कुछ मेरे साथ तीन सेंटेंस करके देखो तो
आपको थोड़ा प्रॉब्लम्स आ जाएगा आप भी मेरे
साथ बनाओ तो सबसे पहले बोलते हैं आ हा
प्ले क्रिकेट बिकॉज है लाइव क्रिकेट
आईपीएल क्रिकेट बिकॉज द लाइक तो क्या होगा
इस पिलर क्रिकेट वाइल्ड इस क्रिकेट मांग
आईपीएल क्रिकेट टीम अंधेर फुटबॉल क्रिकेट
जीवन लाइट बिल स्पीनर क्रिकेट वूलविच
पुष्प बालमा पर आप ले क्रिकेट फिर आई प्ले
फुटबॉल विद है वह बोल अ फ्लू फुटव्वल इश्क
लव कुश डबल वे इस लाइन थाल हाब्स टाइम
सिंपल ही नोट के अनुसार कुछ भी हार्ड नहीं
है इसमें अब यह छोटी चीज मैं आपको बताने
वाला हूं किसके कारण लोग कंफ्यूज होते हैं
जो रूल किया है रोल्स समझ लो रूल है कोई
भी अव्वल जजमेंट रॉयल आया तो जो से
इस प्रश्न पर चलने वाला वर्क उठाकर एडमिरल
को यह लोग ठीक से नहीं समझ कर फिर कंफ्यूज
होते हुए दो सेंटेंस देखो
हेलो हाय डैड आई लाइक क्रिकेट बिकॉज आईटी
कैन क्रिकेट लाइव क्रिकेट बिकॉज ठे कैन
प्ले क्रिकेट आई लाइक इट इज है इस मास्क
रिक्वेस्ट आई कैन प्ले क्रिकेट स्टार
क्रिकेट क्लब तो ज्वाइन से छोड़ोगे क्या
करोगे सेकेंड पोजीशन क्या चैंपियन है काम
उठाकर एंड मिडल अग्स उत्पीड़न के पीछे गया
नहीं गया आपका क्या कर रहे रूसी है न पहले
इसकी लेंथ में तन मन सेंटेंस में क्योंकि
वो डर लगता प्राप्ति वह सेंटेंस फ्रॉम ने
पकड़ा है और कुछ सेकंड पोजिशन फॉर एडवांस
हैं इसलिए क्या होगा इस महान क्रिकेटर
इश्क क्रिकेट पीले रंग का इन सिंपल एंड
कंस्ट्रक्शन ही समझ लो तो कुछ हार्ड नहीं
और
अच्छी तरह का या आईडेंटिफिकेशन मस्ट
ड्रिंक थी ड्रिंक वॉटर मस्ट रीड टीम
स्प्रिंट कटे इसमें स्टेट रिंकल जोड़ते
वक्त मोस्टेड में जाएगा इस ट्रिक करते
वाइर स्टेट बैंक अनमोल कुछ भी नहीं है
कि अगर आपको यह कंसेप्ट क्लियर है भाई
बहनों बोल वाली तो ऐसा और सारे बहुत सारे
कनेक्टर है जैसे वेस्ट है वरन मतलब
ड्यूरिंग फॉल मतलब इनके या फिर आज आज मतलब
मैं 46 साल का था मैंने ऐसे किया वगैरह
ऐसे कुछ नहीं सेम 2 सेंटेंस लेना इन्हें
जोड़ ने ब्रॉन्ज मेडल है यही करना है कायन
इनडायरेक्ट स्पीच आईएस शेड्यूल्ड यह सारा
भी इसी रूप से चलता है पर यह हम करेंगे जब
हम एडवांस कनेक्टर्स लेंगे मुसम्मी भी यह
टू बी वन के डोंगरी के लेकर तब हम यह
देखेंगे पढ़ बेसिक कंसेप्ट से है जो सेकंड
वाली इसकी स्किन के साथ इन के बाद जो वर्ड
वर्गिस जो सेंटेंस आने वाला है उसमें चलने
वाला युवक पकड़ो एंड में लेकर जाओ डेट्स
इन सबको कंसेप्ट समझ में आयेगी तब वह
उन्हें बराबर में कुछ नहीं करना है वहीं
वे अनुकूल मैं चलने वाला वरुणा के एडमिरल
है अब जो नेक्स्ट में 2 मिनट बोल रहा हूं
आप को नहीं समझा तो चलेगा I am Just give
क्विज्जस कवर्धा कंसेप्ट ओके तो को जर्मन
में कभी-कभी यह निबंध आपको आगे भी ला सकते
हो कि वहीं इस टैग मार्क प्रियंका स्थित
वाइल्ड स्टीव मार्टिन का स्टे
कि अभी वह कैसे है कि उसमें क्या किया
पहले अपने ने बंजर को आगे लाया फिर वह आगे
था इसीलिए कंडीशन में हुआ था और फिर आया
है यह सब आपको समझने की कोई जरूरत नहीं है
तो हमारी लिए वह दरवाजे पर नहीं है
क्योंकि मुझे चाय पसंद है मैं चाय पीता
हूं इस नॉट वेरी वेरी लॉजिकल रहे हैं और
यह ट्रस्ट में ऐसा कोई कंप्लशन नहीं किया
इससे भी आपको सीखना है तो स्पेशल यह 1821
में तो बोलूंगा जीवन के लिए भी इसकी जरूरत
नहीं है जड्ड कि किसी ने वह बोला तो आपको
पता होना चाहिए वहीं पहले कैसे आ सकता है
तो यह स्नेप रिजल्ट्स पहले आ सकता है फिर
हॉटस्पॉट्स मैं आपको फिर ओवर का खेल लेना
पड़ेगा कि डिड नॉट वर्थ डाल यह 2 मिनट में
सिर्फ समझ गया भूल गए तो भी चलेगा ठीक है
तो फिर से हम आते हैं अपनी इंपोर्टेंट कर
सकते आज आपने क्या सीखा देखिए हमने
कंजक्शन सीखे दो सेंटेंसेस को जोड़ना सीखा
सबसे पहले हमने बोला कुंड आर्डर एकदम
सिंपल कुछ पकड़ो सेंटेंसेस जोड़ों एब्सेंट
और फिर हम नहीं इंपोर्टेंट फंक्शन की ऐसे
करें
थिस वर्ल्ड एंड वे जाता है और कौन से हैं
वाइल वैन और बोल क्या हो रहा है पकड़ने का
सेकंड जो उसके बाद का जो सेंटेंस से उसको
पकड़ने का उस पर चलने वाला ग्रुप के एडमिन
लेकर जाएगा दीक्षित और बाद में हमने बोला
कि ऐसे अगर आपको यह कंसेप्ट क्लियर है तो
ऐसे बहुत सारे करेक्टर है जो मैं एडवांस
कनेक्ट में जब भी देखेंगे तब हम देखेंगे
मुझे आशा है कि आप सब तो यह कनेक्ट समझ
में आई होगी हम मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास
में धन्यवाद